alors quel est le meilleur et le pire
animateur de jeu et j'ai les huit
extraits de jeux g8 extrait
exceptionnelle alors pour vous benjamin
castaldi qui est le meilleur animateur
de et bien c'est moi je le dis haut et
fort c'est moi à oui n'a franchement pas
assez exploité malheureusement alba et
mais c'est comme ça c'est la france est
gênée mais n'en fais tienne on sait que
dans mon cas je suis dessus dans le
domaine du génie je pense mais non j'ai
l'humilité
j'en ai beaucoup au sénat je me trouve
très très bon et je me kiffe quand je me
voyais à la télé mais c'est une caméra
cachée ou quoi
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est le meilleur il m'a tant
de gens vous donner les résultats du
sondage dans le classement mais oui il
est dans le solide et dedans alors au
top 8 mais en même temps vous avez vous
donné quel est votre meilleur et votre
pire animateurs aux étudiants dans votre
pire dans un instant vous souvenez
sûrement de bastien ces deux truites de
notre classement des huit extraits les
plus drôles de jeux bastien qui est l'un
des candidats des jeux télé les plus
connus c'est à l'époque de julien lepers
était le mec le plus motivé de la terre
entière regarder il environ un million
huit cent mille habitants et la capitale
du kenya
[Applaudissements]
c'est pareil
alors d'une encaisse trop désigne les
signes tangibles qui permettent à la
police bassin les indices oui mes amis
[Applaudissements]
woods pour vous donc c'est benjamin
castaldi meilleur animateur de jeu et
pour le pire si elle ne faire aucun en
fuchsia oued en fait ouais mais non j'ai
ma caméra café continue adultes j'aime
vraiment pas du tout s'est tu sais je le
vois la télévision jouer au jeu mais je
vous jure il est 4 heures c'est
épouvantable c'est à dire dans le
domaine de l'animation on a atteint 0 0
je comprends pas qu'est ce qu'il est il
est pas mal dans le temps dans la côte
de 4 13 passes qui a beaucoup
d'hélicoptères bourgeois - mais mes
dents slam trop de trop de bruit tout
début d'un jeu trop de paroles lui
arrive c'est toujours très mal et moi à
mon avis je ses côtés comme ça fait
chier en instance de divorce
c'est lui le meilleur animateur il me
l'a dit je pense vraiment que c'est lui
alors pour vous jean-michel merde le
meilleur il en reste beaucoup j'ai dit
oui parce que je trouve voilà lé pa lé
pa ni oignons voilà elle est un peu
acide un peu corrosif et ça y va je
trouve ça du coup ça fait ça donne au
jeu un punch que les autres mon poste
l'une des pires années n'a aucun talent
on n est pas du tout drôle à ne pas
pratiquer métal s'était laissée c'est
incroyable c'est isabelle mettent pas
d'accord avec lui mais non tu
complètement dingue
attend il ya des limites à la stupidité
[Rires]
laurence boccolini seraient créés
la sublime halle de l'époque laurence
boccolini animé le maillon faible qui
est numéro 7
elle avait souvent des candidats
exceptionnels et cette candidate elle
est un peu particulière puisque regarder
sa réponse sur la femme du lièvre est
lui à val d'or quelle est la femelle du
lièvre
la levrette
mauvaise réponse super d'être justement
pour vous c'est qui le meilleur
jean luc reichmann il est formidable
depuis des années de l'empathie de
l'humour c'est drôle c'est rythmé
franchement j'adore tout ce qui fait
j'adore êtes d'accord avec moi c'est mon
client qui souffre il est bon il est
populaire certes mais beaucoup
angoissent à un animateur des années 80
dans un style d'animation comme la gaffe
désolé il n'y a pas de moulages donc un
peu à l'ancienne et à l'ancienne c'est
un peu comme un camelot deux fois la
fête foraine ça marche
voilà c'est bien ça mais là vous dirigez
annoncé pas moderne c'est pas modère un
des meilleurs à metz et populaire à mal
être et ce derby est la voulais vous
dire un truc non mais je trouve que
c'est dommage de cracher sur tout cela
était les années 80 comme s'il fallait
avoir honte d'être enfin je veux dire ça
les choses sont venues si tu veux mais
même façon il faut pas cracher sur ce
qui a été un enchaînement mais c'est pas
grave y'a une différence entre être à
l'ancienne ou être un ancien c'est un
ancien et c'est tout à son honneur il
est encore là il est pas super skis puis
on les trouve pour ce faire une date de
péremption
alors moi sinon c'est qu'ils vont
imposer frédéric lopez mais vraiment il
a en fait je non mais c'est pas grave il
amer alors laurence boccolini
et et foucault focaux away sais rien
pour faire un coup elle a inventé un
langage une marque il est exceptionnel
je suis d'accord avec elle alors sinon
le numéro 6
voilà donc les candidats qui nous ont
fait le plus rire c'est un candidat du
juste prix c'est le jour où vincent
lagaf a fait craquer un candidat belge
sur l'épreuve finale de la vitrine ça
aussi très gros extrait regarde 14200 5
ans et plus sur 3200 septembre c'est
plus cher 3280 et +14 1291 plus en 1295
c'est plus intense 1299 c'est moins 14
858 cadets croit maintenant tu letters
me donnant 8
c'est quoi 90e
alors va te blanc pour vous le meilleur
et le pire allait fatalement meilleur
donc vous c'est qui votre pire iceman
reichmann vous bruno guillon c'est un
exploit d'être aussi mauvais chaque jour
je ne savais même pas qu'il est elle
aujourd'hui j'avais dit ferrero sauf
qu'il est beau moderne et qu'il arrive à
s'imposer dans son jeu sans cannibaliser
le contrat celui en revanche que je peux
plus à quai c'est vraiment c'est nagui
vous avez vu ce clip qui fait vieux beau
show qu'il a une fausse en pratique les
gens il fait son mini one m'annonçant
qu'il ne parle que de lui
il faut vraiment une certaine fatigue
non pas du tout 140 même un peu de
mépris une pense qu'à lui
c'est vraiment cessé pour moi ces
animateurs à l'ancienne avec tous les
défauts peuvent avoir les animateurs un
peu comme la gaffe et où qu'ils sont
bourrés d'ego qui ne pensent qu'à eux ne
sera pas content que le programme est
plus fort que qu'on mettrait sa soeur ça
marche très bien entre la science de la
vie donc voilà donc moi c'est quelqu'un
je trouve que ça se voit même pas le jeu
c'est quelqu'un je suis ça se voit dans
l'oeil si vous ne savez pas le faire ça
se voit dans l'oeil que c'est un genre
mais il voit sur la photo qu'il a adoré
ce que tu aimes tu dis ça en toute
amitié
voilà mes choix
[Rires]
carrez
derrière le top 5 des images juste bord
de jeu c'est un jour dans motus une
candidate en panne d'inspiration a
préféré s'exprimer d'une autre manière
qu'avec la bouche regardez vous allez
jouer avec ar roumaine et rui et mayenne
[Musique]
routière route-66 votre animateur
préférons a préféré c'est olivier minne
souriant ou intra le professionnel mais
on a animé des jeux entre fort boyard la
cible que j'adorais mission pire attaque
encore joker pyramide mais n'a pas mal
et le vaut bien
sébastien folin lorsqu'il présentait
harry s'est truite c'est moi en plus
j'aime beaucoup mais voilà mais c'est
vrai que il anime pas toujours ce moment
mais c'est quand même sympa de l'avoir
dit alors et d'y revenir sur le numéro 4
des extraits qui nous ont fait le plus
rire dans les jeux c'est dans attention
à la marche les candidats avaient
souvent de bonne anecdote quand cette
candidate parle de son aventure sexuelle
au lycée son copain en fait il n'avait
pas l'air au top
c'était mal stv regarder
6 la plus folle que vous ayez fait enfin
la situation un peu cocasse ou encore le
tuer si je le dis là dessus et puis j'ai
proviseur du lycée qui va et la tête me
poursuivre en faisant glisser on a cassé
le lavabo des toilettes du bâtiment fait
ne veut pas voir ses émoluments des
landes en plus
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel alors je gère mal d'imagés
vous c'est qui votre animateur prêterait
apprendre à voir le classement dans le
sondage qu'on vous a demandé de faire
avec vous allez voir qui arrive numéro
un matador laurence boccolini je la
trouve à mouy à l'europe elle a un ton
de mère fouettarde trop absolument
incroyable elle a vraiment inventé
quelque chose à la télévision d'accord
et celui que je n'aime pas c'est denis
brogniart oh non
ninja warriors 6 10 et complètement
gâché c'est que des onomatopées des
borborygmes il n'essaie un emploi fictif
il sert à rien de mal tu sois vraiment
un jeu voilà qu'on aime quand même
tellement mais c'est vrai qui barrent la
voie ni matière de nozay d'études
aventure c'est pas tout à fait la même
animation le numéro trois c'est dans le
dès le début des chiffres des lettres
certains candidats étaient des
véritables petits coquins sachez le
j'adore ce lancement comme avec ce jeune
homme est sorti de nulle part qui va
être hyper fier du mot qu'il a trouvé
regardez c'est notre top 3
mature matures
madrid un bac d'eau mais il ya un jeune
garçon de blois ses sorties annoncées
saint-élie ah bon oui j'étais avec ma
sion bernard montiel c'est kivu alors
moi je trouve dans l'empathie
sympathique vraiment agréable avec les
gens ont pu c'est lui qui a créé ce
concept c'est jean luc reichmann a beau
s'y est ce qu'il est vraiment très
dynamique tous les jours tenir l'antenne
comme ça avec la même énergie est
vraiment il est bien il est vraiment
très bien et je me connais moi j'ai fait
des jeux aussi gamme à l'époque en
revanche si au niveau de celui le pire
pour moi mais ça n'a pas duré longtemps
et forcément il avait présenté une
famille en or comme j'avais fait sur tf1
c'est qu'arnaud de sa mère elle a été
très mauvais dedans
vous êtes dur fossiles avec talent à
celui là il a un vrai gros talent alors
dans le numéro deux alors c'est moi
l'extrait qui me fait un des explique me
fait le plus rigoler à la télévision du
conseil je croyais que c'était une vanne
au départ rappelez vous c'était un
extrait d' il ya 28 ans c'est quand
patrice laffont mais le gie a pas ceux
parmi eux partout j'étais mais je
croyais que c'était une vanne mais c'est
vrai mais on voit cet extrait ces
lamelles hamel n'y crois pas je te jure
que c'est vrai que si c'était vraiment
patrice laffont 10 aujourd'hui le csa
trait dessus hein
alors on le sort du label coupe alors tu
feras simple et aucune n'est rien
mais bien heureusement bien pour les
essais d'hiver en fait sa ba 102 qu'il
est méchant il est méchant
[Applaudissements]
mais son remake de la semaine non mais
tous pas le cas pour voir le résultat de
l'image vous montre l'extrême chirac a
fait le plus rire à 10 mais jamais dit
mais non agression passé en plus vous
êtes la plus sympathique
moi j'aime bien effectivement jean luc
reichmann parce qu'il ya une vraie
empathie fait toujours des petits clins
d'oeil comme ça il regarde au fond de la
caméra et ça on aime bien ce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est à nous je suis
seul à personne que j'aime moins en
présentation c'est christophe beaugrand
ça va trop mon truc
webb a fait des jeux n'est pas vraiment
je suis classé bon si rixos et qui par
ailleurs dit la vérité
reichmann je suis pas du tout lui disais
tout à l'heure qu'il est et ringuette
mois là ouais non il est très théâtral
quand il présente un gérant fait si vous
prenez reichmann et maggie qui sont les
deux plus grands aujourd'hui
maggie il est super bon on vient vous
dire en timing est serré et jean-luc il
est bon en empathie ans il était apte
rallye prend les gens l'adorent
depuis dix ans mais je mets ça effet
panique dans l'oreillette ensemble et
puis on avait beaucoup échangé et depuis
10 ans il me souhaite tous les 21 juin
et ensuite je veux faire c'est là qu'il
adore non mais ça tout change pas c'est
pas tout non qui a beaucoup de gens qui
fêtent leurs anniversaires tous les ans
quoi ça fait plaisir
l'extrait le plus drôle qu'on a trouvé
la télésérie fonce sur une grande
feuille sa date de l'émission réponse à
tous sur tf1 un mec du public va sortir
de nulle part
et sa réponse c'est du génie pour moi
c'est le patron regardez
réponse je dirais en ans il est une
marie qui vous mène en bateau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
elle est folle c'est là allez on va
passer un sale quart d'heure sans titre
mois à voulait pas dit ça j'ai pas dis
bah oui bad et il est pas moi celle que
je préfère entre boccolini c'est carole
rousseau dans la traque du grand
concours où il faut poser des questions
en rafale c'est vraiment la meilleure
pour ça mais c'est ben je sors je disais
un jeu wii et le moins bon pardon
maubernard c'est d'allumer la télé tu
t'es présentateur de jeu et franchement
que tes meilleurs comédiens que dans ce
jeu là ça va lui faire plaisir
merci alors on va boire votre classement
direct via des animateurs préférés de
jeu voilà je vous dis qu'elle est
meilleure on irait d'heure de jeu coni
alesi passer l'eau jean luc reichmann
d'arrivants un vincent lagaf qui est
chez nous qui arrivons de nagui jean
pierre pernaut aussi d'affaires des jeux
le bras je m'étais bien sûr c'est vite
cyril féraud dans le corps humain chama
castaldi quand même qui est dans le
classement ouais bravo benjamin et jean
luc lemoine qui était le préféré mais
ils ont fait brûler dans le classement
également il cyril jean pierre pernaut
est bien classé que son père par l'ol a
fait aucun jeu il a fait ce qu'il a à
faire c'est un jour plus isolé ce n'est
pas un jeu voilà il fait en tout cas
c'est votre classement et c'est jean luc
reichmann il arrive en tête juste devant
vincent lagarde s'était il n'y a pas de
chavannes lorsque cole signé par mais
pas de femmes n'y a pas de femmes ben
c'est vrai qu'à pas de femmes
américaines abbaoui c'est vrai vous avez
raison et ben voilà